these guys use brute force
they're strong they're too strong then
they might be a part of the big three
what big threat
androids aliens and wizards that's not a
thing that's definitely it no it's not
there are no wizards
dr schrein is a sorcerer a sorcerer is a
wizard without a hat
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
before we get started in this video
i have a big announcement i'm going to
be able to watch the falcon and the
winter soldier
this thursday and then on sunday i'm
going to interview the director of the
show
kari skoglund and then i'm going to be
doing the falcon and the winter soldier
press conference where i'll be able to
ask anthony mackie
sebastian stan and kevin feige questions
about the show and i'd love to hear what
you would like to ask them
in the comments down below and be sure
to follow me on instagram and twitter
for live updates about the press
conference
now the mutants in the marvel cinematic
universe the x-men
are coming kevin feige himself the
president of marvel studios announced it
a couple of years ago and it is finally
happening and we may know more than we
thought and it may be coming sooner than
we thought they actually might start
introducing some mutants in the falcon
and the winter soldier
and hopefully not introduce mutants like
they did with evan peters and wanda
vision
[Applause]
long lost bro get to squeeze his
stinking sister to death or what
putting that aside the mutants are
coming and eventually they will come
together and that's what is in the works
right now at marvel studios a mutant
movie that will bring our favorite x-men
into the marvel cinematic universe which
is what we'll be talking about today and
not to mention there's a plot leak for
the upcoming project from somebody who
claimed to have heard
discussions on what the film could be
about which sounds pretty dang good so
of course i'll talk about that as well
so the report goes as follows there is
currently a x-men project in development
at marvel
studios this comes from the
illuminati.com and they've been right
about many things in the past
including christian bale being the
villain of thor love and thunder but
even regardless of their report we knew
that the x-men were coming because
marvel studios president kevin feige
confirmed it two years ago in 2019
but the report specifically says that
right now they are currently developing
an
x-men project that is simply titled at
this point the mutants
again this doesn't really come as a huge
surprise kevin feige name dropped them
in 2019 at san diego comic con along
with the fantastic four
and kevin feige during the investor day
confirmed that the fantastic four
feature is well underway at marvel
studios so if they were announced at the
same time
it makes sense that they are being
developed somewhat around the same time
with the fantastic four
obviously coming first but that's really
the whole report that they've begun
working on the x-men project but don't
worry though
we have lots of interesting plot points
to talk about here about this project so
let's start with the working title
the mutants now if you recall what kevin
feige said at san diego comic-con he
didn't say the x-men he specifically
said
the mutants didn't even have time
to talk about the fantastic four
[Applause]
but when he was asked about this in an
interview he said that mutants and x-men
are interchangeable
but this is actually a really good title
because we will actually see the x-men
form
we won't just jump into the team being
formed already and them adding new
members but this way by simply
introducing mutants alone they'll build
up like the avengers did so we'll see
the formation of the x-men team like we
saw the formation of the avengers this
means that we'll get to see great
stories like the story of magneto and
professor x from the beginning along
with any other mutants they'll most
likely throw in there like mystique
however don't expect this to be like
x-men first class from the fox franchise
kevin feige is definitely going to want
there to be a
huge difference between the fox x-men
movies and the new x-men movies that are
going to come in the marvel cinematic
universe
which is most likely why the working
title right now is
mutants and not the x-men so we can
expect to see some characters we haven't
seen on screen yet
or see them in a very different way
which since most fans haven't really
enjoyed the new x-men films is a good
thing
quick note i know a lot of people are
thinking is wolverine coming soon
specifically wolverine possibly
appearing in the falcon and the winter
soldier series coming to disney plus
well kevin feige stated that they don't
yet have their wolverine cast they don't
know who's going to be the wolverine of
the marvel cinematic universe so
although we might see a wolverine easter
egg don't expect him unless kevin feige
was simply trying to throw us off which
could very well be the case
so you never know but don't have your
expectations too high for a wolverine
appearance and besides hugh jackman's
wolverine was
extremely iconic so marvel studios may
not want to recast him so quickly
however the fact that they have a
working title and it's in development
right now means that we could actually
start seeing mutants sooner than we
thought in the marvel cinematic universe
and we could see them as early as in the
falcon and the winter soldier in a
recent falcon and the winter soldier
trailer they mentioned the flax masters
could be part of the big three
androids aliens and wizards what if the
mutants are a part of
the wizards category or maybe they will
go on to find out that their villains
are neither of these three but are in
fact
mutants now i'm not trying to blow up
and hype something up that
may not happen in the falcon in the
winter soldier like one division but
there is a locked in the falcon in the
winter soldier that connects to the
mutants
we know that the show is going to go to
madrapore we've seen it in the trailers
this is a city that is highly associated
with the mutants because
it's ran by mutants wolverine's ex-wife
actually runs magiport and of course we
know that the show is going to dive into
the super soldier program or i should
say
dive more into it and this program is
also known as the weapons plus program
which is also known as the weapon x
program which is responsible for the
creation
of wolverine so again maybe a wolverine
easter egg if we're lucky and sam and
bucky do really seem to question how the
flag smashers are so
strong thinking that they're either
androids aliens or wizards and again
kevin feige mentioned the mutants two
years ago so that's plenty of time to
work them into a show
and not to mention deadpool 3 is already
in early development
this is officially confirmed and
deadpool just might be
one of the first mutants in the mcu that
actually recognizes that he's a mutant
and calls it out
sure we could see some in the falcon in
the winter soldier or black widow but
they're probably not going to call them
mutants they may mention something about
a genetic mutation
deadpool however will definitely call it
out and most likely address the fact
that he's in a new universe with
the avengers carrying three feet off the
ground to snatch up the nearest muffin
crumb
no no no no no no i am not
x-men material at all first off
so it's seemingly clear that the mutants
are going to start to make their way in
the mcu and eventually have their own
title film but when the title film
finally comes what could we expect the
plot to be like for the mutants
well we have a leak posted online that
we won't take in any way as a
confirmation of what's going to happen
but it sure is enticing and sounds like
something marvel would do
and something i would definitely like to
see happen so let's break down what it
says
one part of the leak is that the mutants
is going to be tied directly to
the eternals film and this makes perfect
sense because the eternals
in their own way are kind of mutants the
celestials used their cosmic powers to
manipulate the evolution of lesser
life forms for their mysterious own
purposes and they messed around with the
dna
of humans now they created the
celestials out of this but they also
created the mutant genes and we know
that this is going to be explored in the
eternals so the mutants are indeed
connected to the eternals but it goes on
to say that the project
is initially focused on the story of
moira mctaggart and her ability to live
through the ages and the story of
charles xavier until they both meet in
their youth in the 1990s
moira will have several lives and in
them she will find out about the few
people like her and the current one
where she is a scientist she is made
aware
of the x gene so right off the bat this
would not be the same moira story from
x-men first class or x-men apocalypse
but this would indeed explore her actual
mutant powers
it continues to say that charles xavier
will apparently have a journey from
elitist teenager to human rights
activist when he meets moira he
understands himself as a mutant and he
recruits some more mutants through
reports that he finds and he builds the
xavier institute to house those who have
been rejected by their family
it will be revealed that there were
mutants before iron man and many had the
courage to assume their powers after
tony stark revealed himself in 2008 but
secret organizations captured these
people the film will take place through
the years until it reaches the present
day
after the events of endgame much of the
humanity began to hate heroes and people
with powers and an outbreak of mutants
appearing
frightens humans it says that kevin
feige would like the social class to be
the focus of the film so the first
antagonists considered are the
brotherhood of mutants where there will
be
questions about assuming their identity
to the world or
not and the film ends with humans being
exposed to the mutants knowing they
exist now now again this leak is
supposedly from a person who has heard
conversations about what marvel wants
the x-men to be like
but in no way is this any confirmation
of what is going to happen and could be
way off
but having said that this does seem like
something that would be pretty cool to
see on film
it would actually be really cool to see
that tony stark actually inspired people
with powers
mutants to actually come out of their
shell after he revealed himself as
iron man since tony stark is no longer
in the mcu that would be a really cool
call back to him and a chance to see him
again on screen although it would most
likely be prior footage
and of course we would have to see what
they were up to during the events of
avengers end game before that
and after so the thought that this film
would take place before avengers in game
before
iron man but then after avengers end
game is really cool and if marvel
studios is going to go with
mutants have been in the mcu this entire
time i think it would be a pretty good
strategy for
the initial film to span over several
decades of time
and hopefully we get more information on
this soon so be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest
mcu videos and in the meantime let me
know if you would like to see the
mutants appear in the falcon in the
winter soldier and what you would like
to see in the first x-men film
leave your comments down below don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof